Speaker 1: We are going to look at weekend
campaign events involving Ron DeSantis.
Ron do sanctimonious Nikki Haley.
Who else?
We'll get to PEDs.
We're going to start with Trump.
Donald Trump had a town hall event on Fox
News in Iowa.
The event was so bad, so humiliating that
even the friendliest of friendly Fox News
host Sean HANNITY could not save Donald Trump.
If you want to see what a cult looks like,
it's Trump entering the room to this.
Unidentified: Oh, yes, you're right.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So those are cult members.
As you can see, I'm finishing up Vincent Bugliosi
book about the prosecution of the Manson murders.
Many, many, many, many, many, many similarities
between the family, as Manson's followers
were called and Trump's followers Trump bringing
up.
I mean, listen, I dare I'm not even going
to tell you what he brings up because I don't
know.
I dare you to decode this clip from Trump
during the town hall.
Oh, boy.
And the clip is glitching badly.
Let's hope we don't have this.
This would become a humiliating segment.
Hold on.
Here we go, then.
Speaker 2: Your soldiers, believe me, that's
going to be like the greatest deal you've
ever made is to give us the 28,000.
And they gave us 28,000 soldiers free of charge.
And they stop people.
You know, they have no rules that you're not
allowed to talk fresh to somebody or they
put you in jail for the rest of your life.
These soldiers are tough soldiers in that
sense.
So are ours.
But our soldiers are told to do things that
are horrible.
Speaker 1: I it's I'm as clueless as you are
about what he's talking about.
Speaker 2: If you speak a little bit harshly,
can you imagine if you go back to MacArthur
and you go back to some of these tough generals,
they wouldn't be able to be thrown out of
the military.
How about Patton used to slap slap them around.
You get out there and you.
Speaker 1: Three people clapping about Patton,
slapping people.
Speaker 2: He wouldn't he would have been
out within two days.
He would have been out of the military.
Look, we've gotten we've gotten so bad.
It's so sad what's happened.
Speaker 1: Yep, Completely unintelligible.
Word salads.
And the crowd just cheers for anything.
Anything he says.
The crowd cheers for Trump did make an interesting
claim.
Trump says that he got CNN to do his town
hall at eight instead of nine, specifically
to not compete with his friend Sean HANNITY
and take away ratings.
Isn't that.
Speaker 2: Something?
He'd get their best rating in 11 years?
That's pretty good.
You know, normally normally if you do that,
you have a success.
So they got their best ratings and they want
to fire the head of CNN.
So it's supposed to everything.
It's like April Fools Day nowadays, right?
You get good ratings, you're supposed to get
a bonus.
But and you know what I did?
I said, I'll do the show, but I'm not going
against Sean HANNITY.
Is that correct?
That's why it was on at 8:00.
They had me at nine.
I said, wait a minute, nine, nine.
I said, Nope, I'm not doing it.
I said, Well, then we'll call it off.
I said, I don't care.
They wanted to do it.
I didn't want to do it.
They said, We'll do it at eight now.
How nice is that?
Speaker 1: There you go.
Nice little favor to Sean HANNITY.
And as with most of these stories, number
one, completely irrelevant to whether Trump
would improve this country as president.
And number two, we never know whether these
stories are fabricated whole cloth or whether
there's even a grain of truth to them.
Trump reacting to Ron DeSantis, claiming he'll
have eight years to improve the country.
Trump saying, You really don't need eight
years.
I only need six months.
Speaker 2: People say, Oh, you can't.
It's just like when I hear DeSantis, when
I hear the sanctimonious come and say, we
need eight years again.
If he needs eight years, don't vote for him.
I'll have that.
This country will be hopping in six months.
And a lot of it's going to do with energy.
It'll be hot for six months.
Speaker 1: You know what's funny?
Trump could become president.
And then on the day of the inauguration, January
2025, if the economy looks like it looks now,
Trump will just point to the existing numbers.
He'll say, look, unemployment so low, black
unemployment so low, wages are up, inflation's
down, stock market steady.
There is no way, of course, the economy will
be hopping in six months because the economy
is doing fine right now.
Could we have a recession, a depression?
Of course we always could.
But this idea that it's a disaster and Trump
will fix it.
Laughable, laughable idea.
Trump then pulls out this claim that he'll
end the Ukraine Russia war in 24 hours.
HANNITY actually says, How will you do it?
And as you can see, very shaky.
Trump's going.
Trump's got the talking point down.
I'll end the war in 24 hours.
He needs to figure out what to say when people
ask him, how will you do that?
Speaker 2: But I want to stop the war.
I don't want that war to continue.
And I'll stop that war.
Mark my words, I'll stop that war.
Speaker 3: In 24 hours.
Speaker 1: But we're in a position where the
only way he could stop in 24 hours would be
to force Ukraine to fold.
I can't think of any other way.
He could ended in 24 hours.
Mr. President, I.
Speaker 2: May ask serious question.
How do you stop that war in 24 hours?
I know both.
And frankly, Zelensky was very good because,
you know, he was part of the phone call and
he said he didn't say anything wrong to me,
that he could have gone and grandstand and
said, well, I felt threatened.
I felt threatened.
He didn't.
I get along with him.
I get along with Putin.
It's it would have been much easier to stop
it before it started.
Putin would have never done this would have
been much easier.
Right now, it's a mess.
Now they're hitting Kiev and they're hitting
all sorts of things that weren't supposed
to be hit.
The country is being decimated, by the way.
The deaths are far more than their reports.
You know, when they say.
Speaker 1: Not if you're waiting for the answer,
it's not in here.
Speaker 2: Apartment houses got knocked down
and two people got hurt.
They now know hundreds of people died.
The the numbers are much different than what
you're being told.
I will get them into a room and they will.
And I know in exact way, number one, you tell
one you're not going to get anything unless
you make a deal.
You tell the other one they're going to get
a lot unless you make a deal and you just
sit them and you put them in and you have
to make a determination.
And.
Right.
I'm telling.
Speaker 1: You, the crowd convinced by this
completely unintelligible, meaningless explanation
from Trump as to how he will broker peace
between Ukraine and Russia within 24 hours.
Trump, also during this deranged town hall,
taking credit for ending Roe v Wade, which,
by the way, was not a very popular change
with the majority of Americans.
I don't know that I'd be bragging about this.
This might be why Republicans didn't do so
well in the 2022 midterms.
Speaker 2: I didn't think when I started my
radio career in 1987, I'd be talking a lot
about.
But education, kids, gender identity classes.
Speaker 1: CRT.
I never thought we'd really have.
Speaker 2: This deep debate about whether
or not biological men could be playing in
women's sports.
When you're so crazy on all of these issues,
you know, what is the best way that you see
to settle?
Well, I did something that nobody thought
was possible.
I'd get rid of Roe v Wade.
And by doing.
Speaker 1: That.
Speaker 2: It puts pro-lifers in a very strong
negotiating position.
Now they're negotiating different things.
And, you know, I happen to be of the Ronald
Reagan School in terms of exemptions, where
you have the life of the mother, rape and
incest, mother's life.
So you have that.
And I think, you know, for me, that's something
that works very well and for probably 80,
85%, because don't forget, we do have to win
elections.
But I did something that nobody could do.
And I also made them the radicals, because
they are willing and able to kill babies in
the ninth month.
They're willing to kill babies.
That's radical.
Pro-Life isn't radical.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So this is crazy stuff.
Of course, it's all untrue.
But if I were Trump, I don't know that I'd
be bragging about ending Roe v Wade, given
the unpopularity of that decision.
And then lastly, here, is Trump again, unintelligible,
I guess, talking about documents and Chinatown?
I don't know.
I mean, these these rants really are putting
putting linguists through their paces.
Speaker 2: I have the right to declassify
as president.
He's got 850 boxes that he doesn't want anyone
to see.
He had seven or eight boxes in Chinatown in
Washington, D.C., where nobody even speaks
English in Chinatown.
Chinatown is very it's it's in favor of China.
Speaker 1: Yeah, their Chinatown is it's in
favor of China.
So even with the most friendly questions,
almost no pushback other than like, Oh, like,
how would you end the war in 24 hours?
Trump unable to coherently.
Put together a policy vision.
There's nothing.
He's not articulating any policy vision other
than to sanctimonious is bad and Joe Biden's
bad and so on and so forth.
Now, if you thought that the Fox town hall
was bad, just wait until you see Trump's speeches